2000 madame voilà vous l'aviez comme un
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous vous dite
fière de votre bilan en matière
d'éducation
je veux aujourd'hui vous inviter à
beaucoup plus d'objectivité et
d'honnêteté
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez vos
réformes restent profondément
désapprouvé rejetée par le monde
enseignants les parents d'élèves les
élus locaux et plus largement par
l'ensemble des français
votre tentative de suppression des
classes bilangues est un fiasco total
en dépit de vos efforts de communication
qui ne trompe personne
supprimer un dispositif efficace et
performant au motif qu'il serait réservé
à une trop faible minorité plutôt que de
tenter de l'éteindre reste pour moi l'un
des plus grands mystères du raisonnement
socialiste à vouloir poursuivre à tout
prix un égalitarisme dogmatique ou
sacrifier l'avenir dès élèves de france
vous prétendez également réformer
l'éducation prioritaire
tout en gardant les lycées hors de votre
champ d'action sans même vous rendre
compte de l'urgence du secteur en termes
de moyens ou n'avait eu de cesse comme
vos prédécesseurs dont un certain benoît
hamon de vouloir marquer l'éducation
nationale de votre empreinte et de votre
idéologie
enfin comment pouvez-vous 7 nous
satisfaire de votre bilan
concernant la filière professionnelle où
sont passés les 500000 apprentis
annoncée par françois hollande
l'alternance l'apprentissage voilà les
grands oubliés de votre quinquennat
aujourd'hui en france cent mille jeunes
sortent chaque année sans diplôme de
leur scolarité et un jeune de moins de
25 ans sur quatre est sans emploi
madame la ministre au delà des postures
politiciennes que vous affectionnez
temps dans cet hémicycle
que répondez vous concrètement et pour
une fois sérieusement à ces jeunes
formés par l'école de la république que
vous avez abandonné sur le marché de
l'emploi
la parole est à mme najat vallaud
belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale l'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
laurence arribagé merci grâce à des
questions très large de me donner
l'occasion de dresser un bilan rapide de
notre action éducative de ces cinq
dernières années même si le quinquennat
n'est pas finie loin s'en faut
alors notre action éducative d'abord les
élèves
avons-nous comme nous nous y étions
engagés recréer des places en maternelle
pour accueillir les petits dès l'âge de
deux ans oui trente mille avons nous mis
le paquet sur l'apprentissage des
fondamentaux
oui grâce à une matinée de cours
supplémentaires à l'école primaire et
grâce à des programmes qui ont été
recentrés sur le lire écrire compter
avons-nous enrayer les chèques que l'on
constatait pour trop d'élèves au collège
oui gaza des heures d'aidé personnalisée
qui sont désormais de droit pour tous
les élèves
et grâce à de nouvelles pratiques
pédagogiques qui ont fait leurs preuves
partout ailleurs avant nous moderniser
notre système scolaire oui grâce à un
apprentissage plus précoce des langues
vivantes étrangères l'introduction du
numérique à l'école
les valeurs de la république en
apprentissage l'éducation aux médias et
à l'information
avons-nous réduit les inégalités entre
les établissements oui grâce à des
moyens inédits donnée à l'éducation
prioritaire et aussi à la ruralité
avant nous faciliter la vie et la
réussite des élèves et des étudiants en
difficulté sociale
oui à sa l'augmentation de 40% des fonds
sociaux pour les familles des collégiens
de 10% des bourses des lycéens et 230
mille étudiants qui bénéficient
désormais d'une bourse étudiante là où
ils n'en avaient pas en 2012
les enseignants maintenant avant nous
rétablit la formation initiale comme
nous nous y étions engagés
oui plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'enseignants de futurs enseignants en
ont profité pendant ce quinquennat avant
nous revaloriser le salaire des
enseignants oui nous l'avons fait et
nous continuons à le faire en ce moment
même avec un milliard d'euros pour cette
revalorisation
madame la députée je doute qu'avec votre
programme vous entraîniez de tels
résultats
merci madame